soldiers and city workers disinfect the
streets after bogo time poses a new
coronavirus lockdown
it's the first of a series of rolling
measures restricting
almost a third of the city's 8 million
residents for two weeks at a time
i think that it is very important that
people are aware and keep washing their
hands
the front of their house clean their
shoes before entering their home
we need to stop the virus together
bogotas entered what experts believe
will be the worst phase of the pandemic
and the outbreak is hitting the poorest
neighborhoods the hardest
where few people can afford to stay home
like street vendor alvaro blandon who
had just started recovering financially
after four months of restrictions were
eased
the landlord wants to kick us out i live
with my mother my mother-in-law
two young brother-in-laws and my
pregnant wife i don't have anything to
pay her with except what i managed to
make on the streets
across these neighborhoods small
businesses including hair salons
that had reopened a few weeks ago have
closed their shutters once again the
mayor says the new restrictions have
been planned to minimize their economic
impact and pledged government aid to 700
000 people
living in the newly quarantined areas
the mayor hopes to avoid stretching
hospitals to their limit
but intensive care units are already
more than 90 percent full
doctors associations have repeatedly
sounded the alarm
saying that the health system could
collapse any day at this point
and have called on authorities to
reimpose a strict lockdown
in the entire city for at least two
weeks
we know that various hospitals in the
south of the city are already facing the
dilemma of who to save
who gets a ventilator and who doesn't a
partial lockdown will not be enough to
stop the speed of the spread
returning to a total lockdown is a tough
choice in a city with so many people in
need
but it might become unavoidable if
infections continue to rise
alessandra al jazeera bogota